[Music]
sucker-punch are renowned for video
games with character for video games
that span years from Sly Cooper to the
infamous series but now they are moving
to a more realistic setting and letting
us play as a samurai in the ghost of
Tsushima here's everything you need to
know before you buy
[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades let's set the scene first ghost
of Tsushima is set in Japan in 1274
about the time your mum was born at the
exact time the Mongol army is taking
over the island of Tsushima before
moving on to invade mainland Japan as
this is the time of the samurai we play
as one of the last to wield the katana
to stand against the Mongol Empire Jin
Sakai vows to protect his home from
invaders and with the help of other
inhabitants they fight back the world is
open for us to explore but here is
something interesting of note extra
effort has gone into minimizing the hood
the user-interface you know all that
clutter on the screen it isn't
completely gone but there will not be
any markers to follow Jin instead can
use the guided wind to navigate the
island creating a spiritual connection
with his homeland a quick press of the
button and the wind will gesture the
correct direction to go but there's more
to this nature is here to help in other
ways it's possible for animal life to
offer direction such as a bird flying
alongside or a fox will lead us to a
shrine exploration is organic here from
noticing smoke on the hills or even a
strange shaped tree could hide a
sidequest stay away by God the spirit of
vengeful samurai haunt this forest as
we've seen Jin is a master swordsman
trained to be honorable in battle his
weapon of choice is the katana he wields
if you've seen any samurai movies you
know all about samurai battles they can
be over in a split second and that is
still the case in ghosts of Tsushima the
combat system at its core is based on
three factors speed reaction and
precision a single swipe can finish a
jewel and therefore timing is important
and that's where stun swapping comes in
anyone who studies a martial art knows
the importance of simply changing your
posture it can actually change your
attacks and the same theory is at work
here by changing Jin's stamps his
attacks will adapt
allowing for different strikes to take
place but this will also impact defense
and our parrying options because we too
can fall quite easily we've seen stones
dance we've seen the water Stan
in game play and all my they look
impressive and to those who are worried
about this becoming a hack-and-slash
title there is much more depth here than
first si Jin is a samurai and as we are
all taught the samurai fight nobly
fighting fairly in equal combat with
their opposition Jin will go so far as
to bow after a fight to show his respect
for his opponent it's possible to play
the game as a shining example of the
samurai culture or Jin can embrace the
title of the game here and become the
ghost of Tsushima gaas Jin is still the
same man but his approach to war adapts
to his enemy the ghost is grounded into
stealth so instead of meeting your fall
head to head in broad daylight a ghost
will wait for nightfall and creep up
behind them and take them out not very
noble but highly effective ghost Jin
distracts opponents using firecrackers
and smoke bombs to create openings and
create fear in the Mongol army stories
of the ghosts even begin to circulate
around the island and you can hear the
NPCs talking about their fear of the
ghost oh did I mention there are tune
assassinations a single button prompt to
continue the carnage I should also note
here that it isn't a clear-cut decision
between ghosts and Samurai we are able
to merge the two abilities together to
create our own personal Jin and speaking
of your own character check out some of
the customization options as we battle
through the game dyes and armor sets
become available to Jin some are
cosmetic whereas others offer change to
the game's mechanics small perks and
buffs
which make a certain way of playing more
accessible and ultimately give you the
edge in battle so wear the correct armor
for your preferred play style ghost of
Tsushima has many light RPG elements at
work here too such as charms these are
like passive bonuses which you can find
in the open world or buy from NPCs or be
given them too we've seen chance that
slowly restore health whilst in combat
we've seen poisonous fumes which hurt
our enemies if they get close enough and
the smoke bomb which instantly gives us
back 25% of our health and that's just
three of many maybe I should make a
video about the best ones to find early
on hmm leave that with me is anyone else
getting an assassin's creed Japan feel
from
this yeah me too and you're not a
million miles away in that analogy just
like the Assassin's Creed series ghost
of Tsushima allows for exploration in
similar ways our trusty steed will help
us get around quickly and yeah it's a
quick whistle to bring the Beast over
instantly oh um just like in the
infamous series parkour elements are
here giving us verticality to our
exploration and to get the high ground
on our enemies a new introduction to
ghosts of Tsushima is the grappling hook
which gives us the reach to climb to
unreachable areas so keep your eye out
for secrets around the open world are
many many side quests to find and
complete some found by using your
parkour skills some by being close by
and others rely on nature to guide you
but one has my attention tough boss
fights in the open world with
professional swordsman the ultimate test
of the samurai a duel these battles are
set to test our katana skills and
knowledge of stances how cool is that
the devs have taken inspiration for the
game from Japanese samurai movies and
these fights will be cinematic and I'm
trying to think of another word to go
here but all I have is badass
jewels will be so badass I cannot wait
as the game is based on Japanese culture
and movies it is possible to play the
entire game with Japanese voice actors
so if you're the kind of person who
prefers to watch dragon ball with the og
actors or prefers subtitles overdubs
movies this option is for you
and yet Japanese sounds so much more
epic than English another similar point
to this is the ability to use a filter
over the gameplay to make it feel like a
legit samurai movie this one is totally
for the movie lovers out there and a
great touch and as an extension to this
point photo mode returns a staple of
PlayStation first party games photo mode
is the ability to freeze time in game
reorient tape the camera and take a
photo to show off on Twitter I think
that's the only use and
cool filter and title and this time we
even get to control the weather to make
photos look even more dramatic and/or
inspiring yes I'm gonna waste hours
doing that so to end let's break down
all the nitty-gritty and the frequently
asked questions I've seen out there the
first how long will it take to finish
the game
sucker punch I've gone on record to
state that the ghost of Tsushima is the
biggest game they have ever made and the
play time will reflect that so cast your
mind back to the infamous games and it's
safe to say you'll spend more time in
Tsushima than you would with those
depending on which employee you speak to
the game will last about 40 hours on a
standard difficulty playthrough
attempting to find the majority of side
quests and extras the next most
frequently asked question is is there a
karma system again if you played
infamous you'd probably expect your
karma system and to add to that the two
play styles in ghost op so she must
suggest good and bad playthroughs true
samurai and ghosts but no there is no
karma system here the decision has been
made to tell a single story about jinn
and his need to adapt his fighting style
to gain the edge in battle over invaders
so feel free to play your way without
worrying about karma next FAQ how much
space does it take up I get this
question with games like Call of Duty
taking hundreds of gigs of space it can
be worrying sometime but rest assured
the current requirement space on your
ps4 is 50 gigabytes of hard drive space
and although I would expect that to go
up a little over the course of the game
it's not that much compared to many
other games oh by the way if you're here
early enough there is still a special
edition if that's your thing in addition
to the game you'll get in-game items
like the hero so humor skin set charms
and a cool steelbook for your game and
the digital art book made by Dark Horse
if you didn't know ghost officer Shima
is a PlayStation exclusive and releases
on July 17th it's in two weeks if you're
watching this when I release it so close
but wait we have one more question which
is the most important question ever can
you pet the Fox well see for yourself
so there we have it twenty-something
things you need to know about the ghost
of Tsushima on a scale of one to ten no
I mean on a scale of Ichi to jewel is
how you say it how I tell you that joke
didn't go well I imagine from
PlayStation granade please throw a like
below if you like this I think we didn't
like it I can take the hit don't worry
but why would you still be here if you
didn't like it anyway thanks for your
time it's spilling absolute pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]